se pensavate che mi fosse rimasto un
minimo di dignità in quello che faccio
ancora non avete visto niente raga just
dance 4
ok ragazzi siamo che la festa abbia
inizio ben chiaro se gioco io che cosa
può fare allora quanti morti cos'è sta
roba non eque ragazzi quante ce ne sono
e justin bieber perfetto la draga devo
trovarne una
ce ne sono tantissime non so quanti
ufficio di posso fare sempre se vi piace
e vabbè scegliamo in una calma e con
questo mi sento un figo con la rosa
ragazzi è questo ciò devo fare io io non
ho la più pallida idea
non ho la più pallida idea di che cosa
sto per andare a fare però non lo sapete
spiegare come si gioca sta roba
[Musica]
va bene ma che cazzo grande ragazzi
questa cosa più sexy che abbia mai fatto
s.maria mamma troppe ragazze il
ballerino più sexy del pianeta
altro che billy ballo alle ragazze
giovani per quali gente poi così
convinto le mani
[Musica]
la logan femmina no per me un cazzo è
una cosa è una cosa c'è ogni tanto se
non posso caffè davvero la precedente
sto morendo misura ok ha preso una
stella vaga amo già questo gioco è una
cosa fantastica sono mancante da morire
mai
[Musica]
perché non me lo dai
insomma c'è grande grande
[Musica]
si no
[Applauso]
[Musica]
l'altro grande compreso il tuo filtra
stelle voce
ma che ci siamo scusati finale
[Musica]
[Applauso]
pronto
[Musica]
ma
[Applauso]
no no
vogliamo
però
bravo tutti gli applausi voglio tutte
perché mi sono staccato un ginocchio ma
li voglio tutti grande io io non farò
mai più una cosa del genere mi sono
distrutto un ginocchio credo da qualche
parte c'è una rotula
ma non gli importa tanto cento troppa
vince cioè guardate guardate che sosia
il miglior ballerino del mondo è questa
e per gli haters ma vi giuro che sto
morendo l'alzatore io mi sto sognando
giusta roba si chiuda peggio che fa
jogging con il barbagianni parlò per il
bottino
jennifer lopez e pippo bagniamo grossi
tornare tanto piccola fatto duetti con
tutti manco praticamente soltanto io
quindi va bene così
ok sono cos'è sta roba da buy co
mamma mia che se si no ragazzi questa è
veramente una presa più sexy che io
abbia mai fatto non mi sentite attratti
sessualmente dammi spazio molto
bari e people
ragazzi questa è tutta roba ragazzi non
fatto da vedere a mia madre
[Musica]
billy ballo ancora meglio
anch'io ho fatto gli è stato fatto
[Musica]
egli però che la pagano da parte guarda
caso è il tutto dando parigina
riteniamo prossima 20 piedi tu non io
che cazzo non rimanere di sotto
fantastico no ragazzi non hanno fatto
poi quattro perché c'è le cosce sexy io
non c'ho proposte più batteri
io sono più serio diversa invita geni
per cosa ti credi guarda chi balla
guarda che che sa parlare non è
bianco
piatti
ancora mensili a sola lettura
stanco ma basta che cazzo fai così che
sono stanco ragazzi
a prestare una chicca assurda cosa che
devo fare io la più sexy con la rossa
più sexy ok faccio progetti franca non è
normale con una cordata german si gioca
in 21 ho capito anno la faccio la sua
grande ma cos'è mi sento piccola ma
questa è una cosa ott
cosa sta facendo la chiamano studi non
lo so la canzone che ho cliccato con le
tipe sexy ok go hanno invece lo so ma la
ricordo
[Musica]
e a
e la
[Musica]
questa è una cosa non è che posso
parlare perché non dovrei fuori phuket
mario sta canzone perché veramente sexy
dovete lo sconto di merda eccolo
dovrebbe all'aula con due ragazze io io
questo vi do qualche stop che state
vedendo in un obbligo ormai perché non
mi voglio rivedere dimmi che se forte
molto sexy grazie va al volo ma che vive
era mai capitata a tiro
[Musica]
i ragazzi cè un tanto perche anch'io
però non funziona presenti magari io io
io sto sudando peggio delle classica
delle linee una nuova bella pasta che
fai così a 41 bis al momento non c'è una
parte di tutti
valona
prenditela dietro tutto pronto ma senza
pace ma ancora maggiora solo
[Musica]
rega basta la chiudo qui io sto morendo
dal sudore mi sto sciogliendo non ho già
più le gambe erano ve lo faccio vedere
perché se non già sciolte
io penso che sia il vino più ridicolo
che abbia mai fatto di ordine di
conclude qui per questi episodi perché
sono sfinito veramente non avete idea
fatemi sapere comunque soprattutto che
ne faccia altri perché io data da solo e
non penso
basta io la chiudo qui ma che sto
sperando vi giuro sono ma basta papa
bene cos'è file più dove piace il
tracciato il commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook che come in ogni
video trovate la descrizione per
iscritti iscrivetevi indici vediamo
prossimo i ragazzi